The answer is 1/4. It's easy to see that the probability of heads in step 2
is the probability of heads in step 2 conditioned on heads in step 1
times probability of heads in 1
plus, that's the sum, probability of heads in step 2
given we had tails in step 1 times probability of tails in step 1.
Now, the way I set it up, those things here are equally likely.
However, if we did have tails in step 1,
we would never toss the coin again and just accept it.
It's impossible that in step 2 I flip over the heads. It's probability zero.
Whereas if I found heads, I would flip again and then the 0.5 chance I arrive at heads.
If I look at this, then this all becomes zero,
and these guys multiply to 1/4, and the final answer is 1/4.